hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's Thursday for under just
did its usual weekly dev stream so we're
gonna recap that for you all got some
interesting news to talk about so let's
get started so first up Dominion well
has now replaced tribute as the four
before ranked mode ranks have been reset
so if you happen to play tribute ranked
your rank is gonna go back to what it
used to be the unranked ago through all
the twenty matches to get your Dominion
rank I don't know why originally we
talked about this last week it basically
it used to be Dominion then they changed
it to tribute and now they changed it
back to Dominion I have no clue what
their thought process was on this but
either way that's what they're doing and
for rank promotion and demotion the
bonuses have been reduced to ten percent
from twenty five percent so you're gonna
be earning a lot less if you win a game
we're also going to be losing a lot less
when you happen to lose a game which is
pretty nice I don't know if any of you
guys still play ranked I haven't played
any of the ranked stuff for for honor in
a while let me know if you guys do tell
me if that's a decent change next up
there's going to be a community order
this weekend called Dominion executioner
as a community perform as many
executions as you can the reward is
gonna be two thousand steal
participation is required normal stuff
like a normal weekend type of community
event there's also now a PC starter
edition if you happen to be wanting to
get PC basically it's going to be a
little bit different if you've ever seen
the starter edition for Rainbow six then
you kind of know what I'm talking about
but basically the game for the starter
Edition is going to be cheaper than just
standard edition but you have to pay a
lot more steel to access the characters
so just say for a hypothetical example
the standard edition costs $30 and the
starter Edition costs 10 obviously the
starter Edition is going to be cheaper
but to unlock the characters in the
standard edition obviously it's 500
steel per character we obviously know
that but for this it's going to be 8000
steel per character obviously because
you paid cheaper for the game so that's
entirely up to you if you want to get
the regular PC standard version that's
up to you or you can get the starter
Edition you're just going to have to be
playing you're gonna have to be playing
a little bit more maybe buy a steal pack
and get some extra steel to get those
new heroes it also says at the bottom
that 8000 steal is equivalent to 8 to 15
hours of gameplay depending on how much
you happen to play or it's about $8 the
hit there's also going to be an all hero
bundle which will have the availability
to buy every single hero I don't know if
that includes DLC or not but it's going
to be costing 50
in steel so you can unlock every single
hero right away if you want to but
obviously that's a lot of Steel and we
probably shouldn't be doing that so once
again I just recommend the standard
edition but if you're low on cash and
just kind of want to play the PC version
it doesn't really matter about
characters might as well grab the
starter one another quick update down
the hatch is now gonna be 50% off and
not cost 5,000 steel instead of 10,000
if you don't remember that is going to
be the drinking emo for every single
character so if you didn't get it the
last time when it was a little bit
cheaper and you wanted to get it now it
might as well get it now while you can
cuz it's going to be half off at 5k and
then to end the video we have a new
cheap effect in and honor of st.
Patrick's Day it's going to be a limited
time effect from the 15th of March for
just today til the 22nd so basically you
have from this Thursday till next
Thursday to go and grab it it's going to
be costing seventeen hundred and three
steel or 1703 steel like I said it's
going to be limited time effect I have
no clue what the hell is going on with
this photo with all the checks being
jumbled and [ __ ] it hasn't I have no
clue what this means if there's some
type of T's that they're showing I'm
completely lost on all of this but
either way it's going to be similar to
the Valentine's Day ornament stuff
except instead of having a heart it's
going to be in a three leaf clover form
so that's pretty cool like I said I have
absolutely no [ __ ] clue what is up
with the text and why it's all wonky I
judging by the background it just looks
like a bunch of the heroes really not
there really isn't much to go off of
either way it looks really cool
nonetheless maybe we'll be getting
something in the future maybe this is a
little tease if you guys have a little
bit of a theory about what's going on
with the text or anything I would love
to know in the comments below so
definitely let me know but that guy's
going to be the end of the video today
hope you guys did enjoy there hasn't
really been watching news in for honor I
apologize we obviously just got out of
the new event the apology ons legacy
test your mettle stuff so there really
hasn't been much it's kind of like a
huge huge tons of info for that them
really gonna start slowing down a bit
maybe we will pick up in the next couple
weeks I have no absolute clue but like I
said end of the video today guys hope
you guys did enjoy like the video if you
did really does help me out subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
site a foreign or the leaks the news the
patch notes all that good stuff to keep
everyone up to date on foreigner and
what's going on in the community my two
most recent videos are gonna be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out and with that guys hope you have a
great rest your day and peace out